aquí en el corazón de nápoles hay otro
de los lugares de peregrinaje para
aquellos que idolatran y idolatraban a
diego armando maradona este es el barrio
español en donde ustedes pueden ver lo
son murales muy conocidos esos murales
que han sido pintados sobre los
edificios como este este mural fue
justamente pintado después de 1987
cuando finalmente el nápoles ya consigue
su primer scudetto su primera campeonato
italiano este mural que de hecho ha sido
renovado en varias ocasiones la última
vez hace cerca de cuatro años los
homenajes continúan los napolitanos por
ejemplo vienen aquí hasta esta plaza no
solamente siguen yendo también al
estadio san paolo sino también aquí a
esta plaza como les decía en el centro
de nápoles para dejar unas velas
encendidas para traer algún tipo de
ofrenda tener unos minutos de
recogimiento los homenajes también a
continúan este fin de semana durante el
calcio italiano porque durante antes de
todos los partidos habrá un minuto de
silencio en homenaje al 10